now i've mentioned the famine times
which occurred following the death of
the god emperor lato the second
but what exactly caused the famine times
what happened during the famine times
and how long did the famine times
last the dune encyclopedia refers to
these times as the starvation times
and the book god emperor of dune lato
describes the famines
as a time when the guild would be
largely helpless due to a lack of spice
none would escape the famines not the
poor
not the rich there would be starvation
on a level never before
seen there will be famines and hard
thoughts
here on arrakis too here there
everywhere people will look back on my
tyranny as the good old days
i will be the mirror of their future
but it will be terrible she objected she
could have no other reaction he thought
he said as the land refuses to support
the people
the survivors will crowd into smaller
and smaller refugees
a terrible selection process will be
repeated on many worlds
explosive birth rates and dwindling food
the empire had seen more than three
thousand years of stability prior to the
famine
a stability mankind had never before
known
when the god emperor died there was a
political collapse of a macroscopic
proportion
the effect went well beyond the
political realm into the most
essential economic aspects of human life
lato's empire had been a collection of
entangled economies
bound together by a central power lato
had been that power
many of these interlocking economies
contain
entire planetary systems others were
limited to single worlds
each of these economies depended on
faster than light space travel
in order to maintain themselves but
space
travel required spice during the rule of
the god emperor lato ii
the planet arrakis had been terraformed
it was no longer referred to as dune
the changing world's environment had led
to the death of the sand worms
which meant that spice production had
ceased as well
the god emperor possessed a giant horde
of spice
which he gave out in miniscule
quantities to regular recipients
such as the guild and the bini jesuit
the balance lato had maintained here
would be greatly skewed by his passing
at his death
he told siona atreides and duncan idaho
where his spice was hidden
siege tabor an ancient friman dwelling
place
once home to stilgar the dune
encyclopedia suggests that though duncan
and siona discovered the spice
they could not keep it the spacing guild
had plans in place for the death of the
god emperor
and were likely aided by the bini jesuit
sisterhood
they seized most of lato's spice horde
this conquest allowed the guild to
maintain power for quite some time
until the clay laksu found a way to
produce spice within their axolotl tanks
and the ixians created a method for
spiceless space travel
the book heretics of dune seems to
provide a somewhat contradictory account
fish speakers had taken most of that
melange its hiding place revealed by the
idaho gola
who had been the consort of the famed
siona
the record said subsequent searches had
found more caches hidden behind false
walls
and floors before the tlelaxu invention
however the spice available throughout
the human empire was minimal
there were small hordes kept by great
houses but these were irrelevant
considering the grand scheme of things
the dune encyclopedia states in terms of
the economic health of the imperium
only the caches of the sisterhood the
guild and the emperor were important
the famine times was not technically
caused by the spice shortage
it was actually caused due to the fact
that after the human empire had grown
accustomed to the rule and protection of
the god emperor
there was no obvious successor after his
assassination
the passing of the emperor after over
three millennia upon the throne
threw his government into a state of
chaos from which it never recovered
since lato had been the victim of an
assassination by plotters
who had not planned beyond the death of
their enemy no clear successor to the
throne was prepared to step forward
in the book god emperor of dune latos
states that the fish speakers will
follow duncan idaho after his death
the dune encyclopedia confirms that this
is true
according to the encyclopedia duncan
maintained control of the fish speakers
on arrakis
as well as some off-world garrisons
siona herself kept the power on arrakis
through her connections with the
resistance
and her connection to duncan idaho
the initial struggle of the famine times
revolved around those who chose to
follow the duncan and siona alliance
and those who chose to follow the guild
this war was long and many suffered
during it
there were regions of the galaxy that
depended on an economy
that was bound to the commerce networks
of latos imperium
industrial regions that depended on
their abundance
of ores and minerals to trade for food
were ignored during these times
this produced the famine the populations
of some systems shrunk by as much as 90
percent
traders who dare visit such systems
often told stories of cannibalism
these rumors were consistent once space
travel was again restored by the ixian
invention of spiceless ships the focus
of mankind's great war shifted
the guild was reduced to minor status
within the empire
once the clay laksu managed to produce
spice within their axolotl tanks
their stores of spice rendered
irrelevant
the new focus of war became religion
since the worship of later ii as god had
been ingrained into his population for
more than 30 centuries
it is hardly surprising that his
religion came to form the focal point of
the struggles
though transformed to some degree lato
was no longer seen as a god
but as another messiah such as his
father had been
there also occurred some blending of
elements from
earlier faith with the worship of the
atreides
and their freemen many in the imperium
completely rejected the remnants of
lato's religion
did not recognize the sanctity of the
god emperor or
paul atreides or their associated
theologies
it turned out that the opposing forces
those who believed
and those who didn't were surprisingly
even
this fact was obvious to both sides and
this
even balance was the only thing that
prevented a war
which very well may have destroyed all
of humanity
the area around raqqas was left to those
who kept the old ways
the others with the aid of ixian ships
fled out into the scattering
none returned for fifteen hundred years
the book heretics of dune states that
during the famine times
the planet gamu had been ruined it was
rebuilt after the famine times by the
people of calidan
the encyclopedia states that siege tabor
had also been ravaged during the famine
times
many had become convinced that lato had
hidden a horde of spice there after the
guild raid
the book heretics of dune also mentions
the raids that occurred at siege tabor
the famine times had seen violence here
when desperate searchers won through
this place
that might explain the bodies many had
fought just for the chance to search
siege tabor
after the famine times the benny jesuit
sisterhood emerged in the forefront of
imperial politics and economics
the imperium grew heavily reliant upon
them
which is one of the reasons that when
the honored matres returned
they struck hardest at the bini jesuit
the loosely organized confederation of
planetary governments assembled after
the famine times and the scattering
depended heavily on the sisterhood for
vital services
and reliable communications but old
factions persisted
chome the spacing guild slay laksu
remnant pockets of the divided gods
priesthood
even fish speaker auxiliaries and
schismatic assemblages
the divided god had bequeathed humankind
a divided empire
all of whose factions were suddenly moot
because of rampaging honored matre
assaults from the scattering
the bini jesuit holding to most of their
old forms
were the natural prime target for attack
so organism what do you think of my new
video
pretty good right it was pretty cool i
guess
strange that you human so-called
civilized creatures resort to
cannibalism so quickly once resources
are diminished
well it's true that hard times force
humans to have to make hard choices
even the benny jesuit are pushed to
their most extreme
in heretics of dune and chapter house
dude they're forced to do things they
would have never considered before
things they would have considered
utterly unspeakable what things
well they were pushed to use certain
technologies
ixian tlelaksu their numbers were
greatly dwindling due to attacks by
honored montre
they created golas using axolotl tanks
and perhaps even stranger
they used ixian technology to create
cyborgs cyborgs yes cyborgs
if you must know in the book chapter
house tune the mentat duncan idaho
suggest
that there was actually a reason that
later ii
chose to allow ix to continue to exist
knowing it was a threat to the
indefinite existence of humankind
he suggests that the merging of mankind
and machine
had been lato's plan the entire time
aren't you curious why the tyrant never
suppressed ix
he asked and when she continued to stare
at him
he only bridled them he was fascinated
by the idea of human and machine
inextricably bound to each other each
testing the limits of the other
cyborgs among other things
didn't idaho know the residue of
devotion left by the butlerian jihad
even among the bini jesuit
alarming the convergence of what each
human and machine could do considering
machine limitations that was a succinct
description of ixian shortsightedness
was idaho saying the tyrant subscribed
to the idea of machine
intelligence foolishness she turned away
from him
in fact the concept of the cyborg pops
up
several times in chapter house dune it
seems that cyborgs may have been
intended to play a significant role
in the final dune book which frank
herbert never got to write due to his
death
in the book chapter house dune a benny
jesuit pilot clereby is gravely wounded
and the benny jesuit mother superior
darwin o'draid
decides to preserve his life by turning
him
into a cyborg though she ponders on the
philosophical
and ethical implications of this
cyborg was one of those potpourri words
too where did mechanical additions to
human flesh become dominant
when was the cyborg no longer human
temptations intensified just this one
little adjustment
and so easy to adjust until the
potpourri human became
unquestioningly obedient but clearby
conditions of extremists said cyborg him
was the sisterhood that desperate
she was forced to answer in the
affirmative there it was then
decision not entirely out of her hands
but the ready excuse at hand necessity
dictates it
the butlerian jihad had left its
indelible mark on humans
fought and won for then and here was
another battle
in that long ago conflict but now
survival of the sisterhood was in the
balance how many technical specialists
remained on chapter house
she knew the answer without looking not
enough
oh draid leaned forward and keyed for
transmit
cyborg him she said clarby lives but his
face is replaced with a metal mask
and his eyes are just too glittering
silver balls
oh that's pretty spooky spooky
maybe but then again perhaps it's just a
part of the
natural progression of humankind
perhaps the merging of man and machine
is the only
logical future where we can extrapolate
that humans
can survive indefinitely anyway organism
thanks for checking out my video i'm
gonna go upload it now
see you later activate teleporter
teleporting
fool he's finally given me the key to
destroy him
i can't outsmart quinn's human mind to
escape this dreaded place
but i can certainly hack his machine
mine once i
cyborg him
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you